Instagram it's all Instagram
and uh we've got some friendly people
you can go and talk to and also we have
there's the friendly people Camilla and
Gert
um they're at the booth go and talk to
them there's a heap and heap of prizes
that we have uh and we also have
silently working the TV team upstairs uh
that's the ssw TV team doing a whole lot
of interviews you can go and watch it
live if you want or they'll be
collecting interviews afterwards okay
they're also recording some of the
sessions here so it should be good yeah
Isn't that cool
my goodness how the world has changed
and we have uh
invested quite a bit in that TV team and
we are doing it in Sydney Melbourne
Brisbane and now Newcastle that's our
latest
um office they're all running on PTZ
cameras
all right let's kick off the session
um good morning everyone
today I am doing a session called 10
tips to rocking as an Azure architect
and uh I spend most of my time dealing
with azure
and dealing with uh all the software
developers at ssw it's uh it's our core
platform and these tips that I'm going
to go through are basically a
combination of lots of the conversations
that happen inside ssw to the other guys
con kind of trying to take them up to
the next level from a developer into an
architect
so I divided up the session like this
where we talk about the architecture
Center then I want to talk about devops
and devops in the world of azure and
dollars dollars are super important and
you can't be an architect without
talking about dollars
my favorite topic and often developers
least favorite topic they just want to
do work and then I want to talk about a
bunch of other rules to better Azure so
this is me uh I am the Chief Architect
of ssw I'm also a Microsoft Regional
director been a scrum Master since the
very beginning trained by Ken schweber
and these days uh I spend a lot of my
time working with the technical side of
the business
so and that's our latest office in
Newcastle we have the nice Ukrainian
flags up there don't know if everyone
picked it up but subtle all right and
we've changed everything to dark mode
because we've become cool all right
that's what we had that's what we have
now
excellent so
I want you to pull out your phones if
you'd like and you can scan this QR code
and you'll have an app you'll earn lots
of points and you can run around to the
other guys that you see with ssw on get
some points uh and there's there's a
heap of prizes heaps look at look at all
the bands there's uh
switch it Nintendo Twitches switches
whatever
and lots of other cool stuff
uh Xbox is that cool okay all right okay
now this one is more important this
doesn't install an app I just want you
to QR code this and I'm going to ask
your opinion on something
okay
so scan that and I am going to
ask you who you are
I would like to know
do you regard yourself as one one
person's quick okay are you already a
cloud architect
or
do you consider yourself a Dev
that works on-prem or mainly in the
cloud
so we'll come back to these answers
shortly
but you can see that most of you already
are developers working in the cloud okay
and I have another question for you how
long have you been using Azure one year
up to five years up to ten years or are
you primarily on AWS or Google cloud or
something else so let's find out
I've actually been using Azure since the
beginning anyone remember Red Dog
no no red dogs maybe but yes in the
beginning there was just a few services
and it was easy to say I I'm using 100
of azure that would be impossible today
all right so most of you appear to be in
the one to five year category so far
all right so that means not too many old
people
okay now I did a talk uh many many times
uh it was about the most important
Services inside Azure my favorite nine
uh it's on the web you can read it I've
also blogged about it I'm not covering
that today I'm covering some other
things but if you came because you want
to know the most important services to
be using and why that is a good session
to have a look at okay they're the most
popular ones that we do and I cover app
Services
Cosmos DB API management logic apps
cognitive Services Bots containers and a
few other things
all right I want to ask your opinion on
this
how many people have used Azure
architecture Center
okay if you've used it and you like it
say that if you have heard of it and
you're planning on trying it out say
that
if you've heard of it but you don't plan
on using it it's not up your alley say
that too
all right we'll come back to that
so I want to talk about this because I
think this is one of the first
conversations you have with a Dev they
in our case
they will go to a client and could be a
different industry they have to listen
intently what is required and then they
have to kind of pick the right services
for this project and propose it to the
customer
sometimes the customer doesn't
understand everything we've proposed but
they have enough confidence and they say
go ahead
now you don't always want that because
you want them to understand as much as
possible
pictures are great
so one of the things that I'll just take
you through the the quick steps we have
don't you love this we've got new uh
new checks that did you really click on
that link
even though I just authored the
PowerPoint
right
PowerPoint is improving
uh you can see that we have a whole
bunch of things on when you're first
talking to a customer the things to go
through all right and there is a long
long page on this
but one of these things I particularly
want to call out is don't just give them
a proposal
give them a picture
oh goodness
so this is give them a diagram which is
also explaining what you've put together
in the proposal and there is a video on
this you can watch that but specifically
what I want to say you want to turn what
you're proposing into something readable
by the client
and I'll just go this is an example
Maybe
and this is done using draw.io or it's
been renamed to diagrams.net okay anyone
use that
whoa 90 of you that's cool so it's a
nice way so you just draw what you're
planning on doing uh I always think this
is really important to put in there and
there's lots and lots of examples if you
don't want to use a tool you can do it
in hand handwritten it's good enough and
uh you know take a photo and put in the
proposal nobody cares
so do that but
what you really want to do before you
show the customer once you've worked out
what you're doing is use the
architecture center now when you use the
architecture Center Microsoft has spent
a lot of time and they've uh there is a
rule that we have here I'll just jump
into the Azure architecture Center
you can browse the architectures okay
and you can have a look through here
this is the first thing you should be
doing so let's just say you're turning
up to a customer and it's a health app
all right and you're not super
experienced in that area but you think
you know what the client needs so you'd
come down here and you'd maybe look at
you look at all these I think and you'd
have a look what's there they're well
defined they've got case studies with
them
um you can see like for the identity
security and monitoring here they're
saying all right so this is going to
have Azure ad b2c it's going to have
application insights going to have key
Vault notification Hub and they're
they're like the cross-cutting concerns
across the entire application
and then here is a
scenaris or simple workflow so we've got
the user that's going through front door
through API management through app
service and maybe blob storage or Cosmos
DB all right and then you go down and
have a look at all this they even give
you the Visio file
who uses Vizio anymore
okay two people okay
um and yeah it'll take you through this
and it'll make you consider some things
that you haven't considered right now if
you're just uh
a
you know a younger developer who's just
trying to learn the cloud you might just
say I just want to know about serverless
and you might click on one of these guys
I might say serverless with Cosmos DB
there's 200 results for that
okay well this this looks simple so we
click on this
and we'll see right so in this case uh
there's a shopping cart example so we're
going to use Azure functions Cosmos DB
there's going to be a change feed which
allows these Services out there to be
listening to that so we've got a tax
microservice and a payment one and a
fulfillment fulfillment one and so you
scroll down and you can kind of see how
that works so this is the first step to
being more educated and validating what
you're doing with proven you know
samples that will really help you okay
this kind of if you're going to know one
tip that's a pretty good tip to know
now the only thing that they don't have
is they don't have the um arm Jason or
the
um bicep files which would be super nice
uh I'm not sure why Microsoft don't do
that maybe they will do in the in the
future you will you are seeing them
improve a lot and they're adding a lot
of them
now there's another one that you should
be looking at
and that is these Cloud design patterns
there's heaps of these
and there's a lot and there's a lot of
learning
um you know cqrs it's a popular one
we go through it shows you this this is
actually kind of saying that the normal
example
and we've got uh
yeah we've got lots lots and lots of
examples here so it's just about showing
you how to split the right and the read
and yeah so the whole
lot of detail here so it's excellent and
you know
I'll just take you through if there's
any other interesting ones here
no that one's not bad cue based load
leveler
so this is another pattern that you know
a developer might not be familiar with
it's basically saying look you get all
these tasks you throw them through a
message to when they come out so the you
know the the task might be coming in
look at these little things here they're
pretty cool so the tasks are coming in
at a variable rate you know it's busy
and it's quiet and it's busy again but
what you want to be doing is processing
them at a nice consistent rate how do
you do that how do you get rid of all
those nasty timeouts that keep happening
all right and and so this is
you know this is a whole series of
patterns that you should be familiar
with and I I ask the devs
how many hours have you spent on this
and I would say you wouldn't come across
somebody that considers themselves an
Azure architect that hasn't spent well
over 40 hours specifically on those
sites okay they haven't just been there
and they know they exist they've been
through them okay
so yep
cool um so anyone spent more than 40
hours on those
okay
all right so that's that is uh I think
that's useful uh I am curious what do
you guys think is that a useful tip who
thinks that's a useful tip
most
all right good let's move on to
something else I'd love you to open up
your phones
have a look
tell me which ones you've used have you
used the Azure CLI or the developer CLI
or the GitHub CLI the angular CLI
no react to Eli what's going on there
why doesn't react have a CLI
all right good good good excellent
all right
any questions
so one question that you may have
is what is the difference between the
Azure CLI and the Azure developer CLI
all right let's talk about that
so there is a brand new
um Azure developer CLI
and this actually developers say well
I'll just show you
this new warning that uh PowerPoint is
putting in is getting tired real fast
um but yeah this is the one I want to
show you I I encourage you to watch
watch Scott hanselman's video on this
it's uh excellent and essentially this
is a CLI instead of using the portal
that will create your environment your
Azure environment all the services you
want you want you know Cosmos you want
key Vault you want an app service you
know whatever you want you can use this
via the CLI
now they have templates for the
different scenarios python or net
they've got a whole lot of support for
all the app app Services functions
static websites Etc
and of course once you've got that it's
very easy to repeat it again for Dev
test production okay if you there is
nothing wrong with going to the portal
and clicking and choosing a few things
get learning but when you're at a client
site and you're now working on something
and that's going into that that's going
forward that's going to be tested and
put in production it must be repeatable
so you should be using the the CLI in
that case all right
and it also includes the templates for
the Azure devops pipelines and the
GitHub actions and of course it includes
bicep all right so bicep and we'll talk
about that in a second if you're in a
multi-cloud scenario and you're not just
focused on azure
then you might want to switch it to
terraform okay
so there is also command to tear down
what you've just done so you can get it
all up and running and efficiently get
rid of it
and this is kind of the and this is off
that page that I just showed you but you
basically select the template you spin
up the environment that you want using
the uh azd command line and then you
will have your config
you'll do your coding you will push get
push
that will trigger all the
um
devops processors
deployment and then it's all spun up and
then you can monitor what's going on is
there any errors going on okay so that
is the beautiful efficient uh process
you follow that and get used to it a few
times you're saving yourself heaps of
time
heaps of time this is the right way to
do it
and of course if you see a Dev not doing
it this way tell them oh there might be
a better way of doing what you're doing
all right so that's um excellent for the
first few days with a client you will
finish talking to them and give them a
proof of concept with everything
included including all the devops stuff
that in the past we would put there as
that will go into Sprint one or maybe
Sprint one and two to get all our stuff
up and running because we need to do
that before we do the real work and the
client says no no we'll do that later do
the real work first worry about that
later and they just keep on pushing down
the backlog okay here you start solid
and I think you'll have a much happier
client okay
all right how many people think this is
a good tip for them
okay about half all right
tough crowd wow
I was a lot more excited
all right so next question I have pull
open your phones please
I would love you to tell me if you've
used bicep before
and if you have whether you think it's
awesome or you think it sucks or you've
got a better solution or you don't care
for it because
you're using palumi
or something like that
okay we're going to come back to this
when you've finished answering it
all right I want you to talk about
infrastructure as code how many people
have a High care factor for
infrastructure as code
okay so I'd say 40 of you I'd say this
is something we've talked about for many
years
and it is something that we want to get
right but when you're working with
clients
this type of stuff just doesn't seem as
important as adding new features for all
the problems they have and we are still
not as mature in our industry as we
should be when you look across you know
we go to client after client after
client and this is a recurring pattern
so
I want to First explain to you the
problem for those that aren't familiar
with that
so we have had a long old rule about
manually creating resources in Azure
okay and so let me just just show you
this little thing people come in here
and they will choose what they want go
forward and they create all these
resources that's their first experience
creating a web app and they continue
that experience down the track and
straight away you say no no no no all
right now you can be using um exporting
that as uh I'm Jason all right which is
something because now we can repeat that
the problem is
we are kind of used to nice things like
C sharp which is easy to read and easy
to debug you know if you think about it
really
Jason is a data format and they've tried
to
inject programming constructs in there
and so there's tools that have come out
such as Pharma but the generally
accepted one now is bicep
all right
so there's of course other ones like
palumi and terraform and other ones but
bicep is Free devs Like Love free stuff
right so that's good now
bicep is a lot more readable it is
purpose built for this particular
problem of uh creating resources and
representing your Azure infrastructure
and
when you have a long
bicep file you can modulize it you can
take pieces out and make it a lot more
reusable
so I just want to just quickly show you
this
oops
so let's take a look at an example here
is William lamberg's example he did a
number of sessions on just specifically
bicep and getting deeper in there
there's some slides there's some videos
that we put up on ssw TV if you want to
get deeper into it but I just want to
show you what it looks like I'll just
jump into demos
uh he's got these registries
and he's got a full stack web app so
it's just an example all right so let's
just say he had a full stack web app and
he has got some bicep files here what
has he got here here's his main one and
I just want you to see how it reads
obviously it's a lot nicer than Jason
um it is purpose built for you you can
see he's got a this is probably very
important to know he's got a module for
key Vault so he's separated that out
and then he's got another module here
for what is this one
for his storage
and he's got another one here for his
database and his web app so he's split
all these out into different modules
okay so that's a more mature way of uh
separate you know separating out these
bicep files
and I
I think that you know once you've done
that and you look at some plenty of
examples on the web of how to do your
bicep files the next step is how do real
Architects modify all this and you could
say devops people as well
um
what are they doing in in vs code so
this is our
only option
you jump into vs code you get this
extension and you will get
and we've got a video here we go look
anime GIF and you'll get nice
intellisense this is a nice way to edit
and author files right
now I just did say to you that you must
do this in vs code
because that's what I told Melbourne so
Melbourne will be doing that only that
way because a few weeks ago we got a
visual studio add in so all right so if
you come across anyone from Melbourne do
not tell them okay
so
um
yeah and that's that's the extension for
visual studio
okay so you can see that that is the the
best way of authoring bicep files
all right
who thinks that's a useful tip
um okay 60 not bad
okay
let's talk about another topic
Bill shock
now I have a lot of developers when they
first start
picking what they want for a project
they are Keen as mustard and you look at
their plan and there is a lot of
services in there
and you say all right so have you worked
out the cost of all these services
uh no not not yet just making plans all
right do you know the cost of everything
you've selected it's every Azure service
including the kitchen sink in there
well no I haven't that we'll worry about
that later okay and it is a mature
Azure architect we'll talk dollars from
the beginning and they'll be thinking
about dollars from the beginning
um now if you haven't had anyone ever
get cranky at you because of the Azure
expense well then you're not going to
worry about this okay when you have you
will worry about this
so
um and it's and this is the reason that
business owners are frightened of things
like Azure compared with their
on-premise stuff this feels like it
could be a runaway train
now if if you're talking dollars from
the beginning with a client they'll have
a lot more confidence that your
cognizant of the dollars rather than
just the work you're doing
so
how many people here know their monthly
spend
okay
I would say we have less than a quarter
okay so that is something you should be
aware of if you've got a just a simple
web app database reports many times I
asked they say no friggin idea okay they
do not know
so you've got to plan ahead and it's
easy well it is easy now with this
pricing calculator
so this pricing calculator
is this all right
so
gotta volunteer
who's smart
oh no one
who loves Australia
okay all right so we I wanna before you
do this I'll tell you the first thing
that
you end up spending a little bit of time
on this you pick all this you you work
out
um
what services you want and you work out
the costs and then you lose it so the
very first thing you should do
is you should log in right
right
disagree
wrong
we don't log in up there or you can try
but it won't log in if you do you want
me to You'll log in and you won't be
logged in okay
I don't think you believe me I'll just
do it
well
does anyone do this
just me get get annoyed by this
all right
so we're in
we've gone somewhere else
back to my pricing calculator oh I'm not
logged in how weird is that
because that is just put therefore
just to make it feel good
if you want to log in you click here of
course of course you would click there
all right now we're logged in all good
there there's our login all right that's
the way you don't lose your stuff ask me
how I know about this
so
let's assume you're talking to a
customer and they just want uh they want
an angular SQL data based solution all
right we'll do an easy one okay well I
think we'll put that up in the cloud sir
yes I'll be happy all right so
um I click app service it got added I
don't know where I got at it it got
added somewhere
if you scroll down the page you'll see
it got added down here all right so that
monthly cost is four dollars that's
great oops there's a few problems here I
need to change this to
um Australia
how many people have changed this to
their
their correct City more than a thousand
times and it still doesn't remember
okay
and now of course oh it's now gee but
look at how they rip us off of living in
this fine country it's now 68 that's
Aussie tax
uh and of course we want to save some
money so we'll switch it to Linux and we
are in business you know back down to 13
bucks
beautiful and the basic tier that basic
tier won't get us very far on a real
production site I think well first of
all you could you could tell be before
you can see there's only you know a gig
you know less than two gigs so we'll go
to basic oh sorry we'll go to standard
that will give us oh that's no good I
want more RAM than that so I want at
least four gig to be up and running and
I'm at 87 dollars
so I'll go to 3.5
now I'm at 175 it's getting expensive
now for an extra couple of gig of RAM
there is a better way of doing this
if you go to premium V2
and I still get my two gig of RAM but I
get ssds as well so much more and same
price
go figure
so that is a better choice
anyway that is that can I give this a
name I'll just call this um classic
um
uh app
and I'll just say angular app
uh plus SQL we'll need a SQL database
and um
where's SQL there we go we'll click on
SQL
look it got added I think it should spin
down here to show us where it got added
but we got our first bit
and we've got our SQL database here oh
of course I must say Australia again
uh what do we got
the cost oh I didn't even see the cost
go up but it
trust me it increased from probably five
bucks to 400 bucks for living in
Australia
um
and uh
this is expensive 400 bucks
so we could switch to DTU okay this is a
blended rate for CPU Ram disk IO and we
are now down at a much more reasonable
price okay
uh now of course this will depend on how
much usage you get out of this but
that's pretty good any complaints by
anyone
uh if you were to go with standard
uh you'll find it
you'll find it increases a little bit
so
that's good
I am going to just have a look at that
cost now generally when you tell a
customer you'll give them a
I'm getting good at this you'll give
them a
a yearly cost that's a good way of doing
it now I'm just going to give them an
alternative you can come in here and say
you know what you could do a static site
static sites are pretty good and we
could use Cosmos and Azure functions
that might be a more modern way of doing
it so we'll come in here and we will
choose
oh look you can see these are the
popular ones but I can't even see stake
sites but stag sites are cool let me
just scroll down where where would they
be sitting web
probably
and stake websites so let's go down here
we have we'll call this a call
static site
and you can come in here now that will
run that free one but if you want to
have front door with Azure functions
you'll need to choose standard
and now it's gone from zero to nine
bucks but it's still very cheap and
you'll need a database as well so I'll
come up to the popular stuff and I will
add in Cosmos database
and now we have a comparison of like for
like
and we'll just what have we got here
um
23 so you can you can do the costs here
but they're they're
this one is clearly easy to choose and
much much cheaper
so
that is a thing that you should be using
as you're picking Services you give it
to the customer what you're proposing
and the the proposed cost from the
beginning don't don't encourage them to
need to ask you about dollars like that
so for example there's a normal service
146 dollars or the Azure stake sites
with Cosmos 50 bucks okay and give them
you can have that or you can have that
something like that
and you should be able to
talk every customer into pre-paying for
at least one year usually you can get
three years out of them sometimes they
don't want to give you anything they
just want to say just for the time being
let's just see how this this runs but uh
you've got to talk them into at least
the one year
for their own savings and of course I've
used a contrived example these things
get very expensive very quick
all right the other thing I want to talk
to you about is monitoring so that's in
the beginning picking stuff and showing
them the cost then it's about monitoring
because things go uh out of control and
that's what they're worried they're
always worried about so how many people
already set up alerts on their Azure
spend
so there's a
so I would say less than a quarter there
this this bit's important and not hard
so you're going to cost management
billing and then you come over here and
you go cost analysis
and then you look at this now this is
the monthly cost going up and up and up
and then at the end of the month it
resets
or you can be looking on a daily basis
you can be look there's so many
different ways of looking at your spend
but basically you want your spend to be
normal
and not up crazy and down without
explanation if there's all these Peaks
and things going on things are happening
and you don't know about it now you
wouldn't give a credit card to your
partner without a limit would you okay
same thing here
the other thing to be thinking about and
this is happening more and more you can
read some stories about this is these
denial of wallet attacks these are
uh
Vigilantes I guess who are
trying to damage a company financially
just by you know uh increasing their
Cloud spend so we have some rules about
this
but you you want to set up alerts and
you can't set up an alert till you have
a budget so you jump in and you click on
budget add and then you'll have a budget
I'll just uh there is um one of the
guys here
um Bryden Oliver he talks a bit about
this stuff uh and you can talk to him or
there's also Matt Wicks as well he's
you'll get lots of information but uh
there's a whole bunch of stuff about
managing costs this is a really
important thing to do
um
and then you've got your budget once you
have your budget great now we can set up
our alerts and that's what you're after
and
there's your cost alerts you go in and
set up your cost of looks all right
how many people think this was a useful
tip for you
okay so this we're getting about 80 all
right so we're talking dollars that's
good
all right
the other thing I want to bring up and
this is about the on-prem stuff
and I bring this up because it's a hard
one to convince a business owner an I.T
major about this because they will focus
on the monthly spend that they're
potentially incurring on Azure or the
cloud
but when you talk to them about the
monthly spend on their
on-premises stuff
it's not a really a monthly spend we
already have that like that's that's not
in the equation
yeah but
like do you have an idea what that
monthly spend is well there isn't really
like there's a air conditioning costs of
course it's very small it's it's not
it's not in the equation and that's
probably because it's a sunk cost they
they don't really believe it is a cost
it's not
um going to be factored in part of the
decision it's more comparing what you're
going to be stung for from Microsoft
essentially
so what is the cost it is not that hard
to tell them now so
I will tell you most of the time they'll
say they don't know what the cost is
you come in here and you can Define your
workloads you can add a server workload
here and answer all these questions
answer the questions about databases
About Storage about networking and then
they want to know more about what you're
paying for software's software assurance
um virtual machines electricity costs
and by the way all this stuff is there
by default so you don't have to do very
much apart from putting some of the
specifics you know and they will if they
if they want to dispute this cost they
will very quickly tell you well that one
isn't included so you'll get closer to
that number so there is a lot of costs
here they will end up get very quickly
you'll end up with a cost generation and
I've put in some screenshots here just
so you can see but it is
um
it's not hard that they're spending way
more than they ever thought they were
and this will give them a shock and then
they'll say yeah that's that's somewhere
on in the right Ballpark and it will
increase their their
taste for Azure or any other clouds
all right so and it's it's useful in the
right scenario and it doesn't take you
much time
how many cares about this one is this a
useful tip
all right it's about a third of you good
let's talk about learning we all want to
learn we all want to get better Azure is
a monster right there's so much stuff to
learn and it's all there in
docs.microsoft
right
so where are you where do you start well
if you remember this scenario when the
JavaScript book was released and then
the good parts was released you know
which one everyone bought okay
so it's the same story here now the very
first tip I'm going to give you
is this Azure developers guide
now this thing
is free great it's 140 page PDF it is
released each year it covers the basics
of cloud native apps visual studio and
the general devops story from Microsoft
okay here it is
I encourage you to start with this okay
it's a nice big PDF
and you'll learn you'll learn a ton of
stuff
now
I am also going to tell you that
learning Azure beyond that first step
depends on
how much you want to spend
some want to spend they're comfortable
spending 500 bucks a year summer tight
asses and they want to spend nothing on
any of this stuff and there's plenty on
YouTube so I would say you can
put it into from 500 down to zero and
your classifications are essentially am
I going to buy pluralsight or LinkedIn
learning or udemy or YouTube right so
that people are in different
classifications here now what I want you
to understand
is
by just watching these videos or reading
this documentation
you don't learn as much as doing it
and watching it and doing it and
watching it but you have to have your
Azure instance you have to be paying for
that you know you have to
create it tear it down Etc
you have to factor in your pay as you go
cost with Azure now there is a solution
for this and this is Microsoft learn and
this one
gives you the tutorial and your Azure
instance of course when you finished it
it automatically tears it down but this
is a very nice way of learning and doing
learning and doing and it will
accelerate it much better than any of
those other alternates so and they have
different parts so essentially let's
just say you want to get up and running
you want to learn what devops is
ETC and do some basic create a new
project
Etc you'll have this and there'll be
eight modules and then you might want to
start doing it Enterprise devops okay
let's get a bit nastier and there's
server modules here and then you know it
goes on and on okay so that is something
worth looking at how many people think
that is a useful tip for you
okay all right I think that's around 80
so that's a popular one
next one I want to tell you about is uh
click UPS
you don't want to be deploying your app
by going Azure portal Resource Group
click to app service
Advanced tools drag and drop different
artifacts
that's not the right way to do it okay
that's click UPS in addition
um you don't want to be you want you
don't want to have a hard time debugging
like you're getting a timeout you want
to
increase
a timeout value you can go into the
portal find the right setting change
that restart the server Etc uh or you
can be using the Azure CLI which is a
nicer way but it's not that friendly to
do it that way so we work inside vs code
and visual studio right so install this
vs code
Azure extension pack and you'll have a
much nicer experience okay in your
sidebar you will be able to explore what
you've got and you'll be able to right
click and change values restart things
so that is the nice way of doing it it
avoids click Ops and it avoids
um
painful debugging so it's much easier
this is the the tool
um
I I think that you know that's a really
nice way of doing it
and uh this is what you typically will
be doing in a Dev environment this is
what you're doing when you're doing your
initial proof of concept I'm not saying
to be doing this long term of course
once you've got going and you've worked
out what's going on all the right stuff
should be being done in proper devops
processes in GitHub actions or Azure
pipelines Etc all right
beautiful
and don't forget one other small thing
Visual Studio has a cloud Explorer as
well so you should be having that
all right those tips
useful
hmm all right I will say
Touch under half
all right
there is another very useful tip for
Azure Architects and that is this site
now this is not a Microsoft site
although it was done
by a Microsoft developer initially
so this guy from Microsoft he just did
heaps of these
articles and these articles
um
any of these articles they're quite
detailed they tell you exactly what to
do so let's just say
your your Society is getting swamped
you could come in here and just type
scale
what do we got
how do you scale Azure app services I
don't know so you click on here and it
will tell you
exactly
what to do
so you can all right so this is how you
manually scale and this is how you do a
custom auto scale
so it every single bit is told to you
and there is
pretty much every scenario you can
imagine
in a normal set of problems from clients
is on this side
okay it's your secret sauce
um
and it's uh it's actually I think it's
all on GitHub yeah
so you could edit it if you thought it
was wrong
maybe you can't trust it after all
right so how many like that tip
okay all right 70 good
now the other stuff is make sure you're
casing your common traffic using front
door you could be using cloudflare that
is a important thing to be doing
um one other thing that we talk about a
bit on a project and there's a video you
can watch but and there's a rule here
but in a project make sure somebody is
assigned
to be a cloud architect so a typical
project typically has a couple of
developers maybe three or four somebody
is a solution architect others are
software developers you need to have
One Cloud architect that is responsible
just for the cloud architecture on a
project you don't typically have a
project software developers throw them
in a room and don't allocate a scrum
master
um I think you end up getting yourself
in trouble without a cloud architect
that
um who is the throat to choke when you
ask a team all right who's in charge of
the
um the cloud story in this project
they will typically say oh we all are
you know when everyone is no one is okay
so it's better to have a role somebody
in our team is taking on the
responsibilities of the the cloud
architect there's so many problems that
will happen where they J it just happens
um and you want somebody to be caring
about
um load security and cost somebody must
be responsible okay Optus should have
had one of those shouldn't they yes
all right
I also want to just throw in a couple of
quick bonus ones
um
this is a nice little site it's it's
handy sometimes
and it just will like when you're
you know remoting into another box
you're not really sure what the
differences are right now depending on
where we are right now obviously
Australia East is the quickest and
Australia Melbourne is the second
quickest
and I don't know I don't I didn't know
that Japan East would be quicker than
the west coast of the USA I thought the
pipe to the USA was way bigger and would
be faster
okay so
this is very handy to get a quick idea
of what's going on if you want something
a little bit more advanced
Azure speed is good
so there is heaps you know little test
file uploads and lots of stunt stuff CDN
tests
Azure regions availability zones there's
a lot of good stuff here
um unfortunately he's
he's prostituted his site with all these
ads everywhere and just ignore all that
stuff but it is a very good site right
all right cool cool
one more
okay that is um
new services are being spun up you might
be at the very beginning of your project
you've got a long Runway
that might allow you to potentially
choose a service that is not uh that's
got you know it's in preview if you are
doing a site that's going live very very
soon you do not want to be doing that so
you want to know what's available right
now what's in preview and what's in
development you could do lots of I don't
know you could Cosmos
or actually containers that'd be a good
one
and see what's going on here I'm using
containers I don't know what's current
what's what's new what's what's live now
and this will tell you all that you can
set all your different
um I just want to know what's available
now all right I just want to know what's
in preview because I want to use
something cool
okay so this is a helpful little site as
well
all right
so
um I am going to finish it off there I
think we have a few more minutes I will
encourage you to scan that if you scan
that you get some extra points give
yourself some extra prizes as well
um
I want to go through the answers you
guys gave us
so most of you were Developers on-prem
I feel sorry for you okay
I have some other advice
so
um good good good
excellent
and we've got 20 of the rumors the
actual Cloud architect says that's
awesome
all right
most of you as we learned before have
been using Azure from one to five years
I'm surprised there's no one here oops
no one here that's been using it for
over 10 years
no
what about you William
hmm
um
so uh the Azure architecture Center most
of you had not heard of it okay well
that's that's all you value in that one
because that's uh that's the golden egg
that one
um the CLI tools which ones have you
used okay
so the Azure CLI angular clo got some
front end people
and the developer CLI not many
okay
great
and
bicep
okay so a third of you already know it's
awesome for the rest of you I would say
it is awesome
and it would have been awesome if we had
this many many years ago because
Microsoft have inflicted a lot of cruel
and unnecessary punishment on us for
many years
and this is a much nicer way of doing it
and get on board on bicep okay and
finally Microsoft came up with a product
that has a cool name
how often do they do that
must have been the next googler or
something
um Bill shock
have you experienced Bill shock look at
you
so many of you haven't
ah
but these people I'm sure have
good stories to tell you about when they
weren't monitoring their costs
or they put it in and it was small and
they weren't monitoring and then it
neither was the business I bet you
um when covert first happened we were
going through all our Azure bills and
I'm sure most businesses were too yes
so um after we canceled all the free
pizzas it was straight unto what's the
Azure Bill where can what can we kill
so in summary so I went through a lot of
different tips I've tried to pick the
good ones from our rules
um there's heaps more but the
architecture Center is your number one
there's the rest if you can get your
devops story nicely and uh if you don't
know bicep which is two-thirds of you
get a handle on it okay
and once you've gone through that
Microsoft learn
you can put in your LinkedIn profile
okay you can put me as a reference
nobody checks them anyway so uh
then the other thing is to do and worry
about dollars from the beginning
dollars are really important
thank you
[Applause]
any questions I'm happy to take
questions too
question sir
do you have any suggestions or
um which is good but I
one of those things you just don't know
how it's resolved
so a big question is about Bill shock
and application insights
it you know you want a lot of logs when
you have a problem most the time you're
getting a lot of logs and you're not
using them has anyone had Bill shock
with application insights
two three all right so um what is what
is how do you deal with that one
budgets and alerts
same
um
sampling so it only does like a safety
job for logs that would provide
absolutely everything you can bump it up
when you have a real issue that you're
trying to pin down
the problem with application insights is
the same as anything else if you have a
budget and you're watching it and you
have alerts and you're using them and
you're not getting what you want and you
need more yeah the you don't want to be
using you just don't want to have the
logs there that are running away
you know there's just and also it has
performance implications as well so you
just got to be careful on that
any other questions
has anyone experienced a denial of
service attack
and did you get to the bottom of where
it was coming from
yep
and what was the story
and were they specifically targeting you
right
um how long after you they started did
you discover it
right
yeah when these type of things happen is
when you learn which things that you're
missing logs on
um and it you know there's there's a
long range of different things uh
sometimes uh your firewall doesn't have
long logs uh there's a there's a lot of
different things where you're just not
keeping enough uh logs it's you know
we've been through this and it's been
very painful
um when you're blind
yeah
right
um
how many people here have experienced a
Cyber attack
right okay
um I think we have certainly learned a
lot of forensic cyber firms that will do
kind of walk over different environments
and tell you what pieces are missing and
what stuff they would need to be able to
solve this easily
it's been really good learnings other
companies sometimes
get somebody
who is authorized to come in and shut
things down and say go back to backups
and it's pretty extreme but it is a very
good way of learning when you can be in
a controlled
um you know basically you've got to walk
through this stuff yes
any other questions
all right that's a wrap uh thank you and
enjoy your conference
[Applause]
foreign